[Music]
can i pitch you two ideas and you tell
me which one you like better
all right these are two kind of like
side hustle ideas that i think could
turn into something big but
they're businesses that are not hard to
do
they would immediately make
somewhere between 500k to two two and a
half million dollars probably within a
year or a year or two of your business
of doing it
profit i like that all right so the
first one is
i'm gonna call it um
baller doctors okay what's baller
doctors baller doctors is
you're gonna go to med schools all
around the country and you're gonna put
[__] you know
ads slash flyers up and you're gonna say
hey
before you graduate
do you wanna know how doctors become
millionaires um you know faster you know
some you know the average doctor becomes
a millionaire in 12 years
i can show you how it's done in five
and you basically host a seminar and you
you definitely lean into the
get-rich-quick stuff because you know
people are curious but you you build in
enough trust but you don't bury the lead
you're like look
even doctors are greedy even doctors
agreed even doctors like money might be
the the better name for the seminar um
and and you're going to host a seminar
and basically you're just going to break
down the business of
most doctors spend all their times with
their all their time with head and you
know heads buried in books
and think about customer you know
patient care as they should
but at the end of the day a lot of these
guys want to go out they want to own
their own practice or they want to
figure out should i be joining a
practice should i go to a hospital
should i
um you know start my own how do i get
the money to do that how much money did
this make
and i think if somebody just made a sort
of business in a box uh seminar where
they just explained look here's how it
usually goes you put in this much it
takes you this long here's a sample p l
with what your costs look like here's
how you make money in your practice
route here's how you could do a group
practice here's how you join a if you
join a hospital here's where you are
after five years um like did you know
this by the way if you're a doctor and
you work in a non-profit which most
hospitals are non-profits for 10 years
all of your student loans
that's amazing same if you're a lawyer
if your my sister did it if you're a
lawyer for
uh the government you get a lot of you
get for loan forgiveness right so
basically you just do like a personal
finance slash business crash course for
doctors and you do that all around the
country
and then some percentage of those they
actually are going to go to you for like
you can create there's they'll pay for
the session or they'll pay for like the
upsell so you might do the session for
free
and then you say by the way i have like
the detailed guide with all of the
business like templates in the in this
thing
uh you know plus like you know whatever
i got all your i got all your docs and
templates and it's all fleshed out in
detail
this is you know four thousand dollars
and you know
you could buy that mastermind thing and
with it comes like a coaching call
whenever you're ready you can always you
can always hit me up and i'll help you
with this stuff all right that's
business one i could play off this
so let me tell you about this so there's
this blog that i read it's called the
white coat investor have you heard of it
not that but i'm in a facebook group
called white code investors which is i
think probably the same thing it's dr
doctor's investments
so if you go to it you'll see it's a
little uh
stale like it's probably been around for
a while
and it gets a lot of traffic i read it
because if they just talk about people
earning high income and like the like
the lifestyle and i just
it's fun and a lot of my doctor friends
read it
and it's incredibly under monetized
and interestingly you know how much
traffic i looked at this sheet
like 400 000 a month oh my god i mean
look at this thing maybe six maybe six
hundred thousand maybe maybe more i
think
a lot but if you look at the draw the
traffic source it's like a good ass mix
yeah it's like six hundred thousand
should we bleep this out this is a gem
bro this is a gym why are we why are we
giving this gym oh here
here let's find out how much traffic
here's how you do it so you go to the
very bottom you see where it says
advertise with us click it oh man this
is amazing so they get um
a million page views a month
so
i think and interestingly if you go to
um
i looked at the stats for the fastest
growing youtube creators this year as
well as the fastest growing tick tock
creators and something like three of the
top 10 were dentists and then a couple
other were doctors and it's usually
young doctors who talk who make jokes
and lifestyle content on tick tock all
about like the doctor lifestyle so they
make jokes out like you and i probably
don't understand but i don't know maybe
like a joke about like sleeping at the
hospital or something um and they
they've gotten millions of follow
followers so i think there's a world
where you could do that and sell a
high-end membership that's thousands of
dollars and do exactly what you're
saying i like i completely agree with
you i think this could be a good
business i don't think you could do it i
think it'd be real if you did it
full-time you maybe could do it in a
year but uh yeah it's a this is a good
business you're part of a white coat
investor yeah i'm looking at their
facebook group you're part of this
facebook yeah i love joining random
niche facebook groups like this and just
see
77 000 members
i can i i would bet my life i could make
three to five million dollars a year
with a facebook group for doctor
investors
oh it's a okay listen it's even better
it's a closed facebook group that gives
physicians dentists physical therapists
attorneys
uh pharmacists and other similar high
come high income professionals uh it
basically helps them but dude how did
you get into this did you tell them that
you're a lawyer yeah i just said i was a
doctor
but look at me i look like obviously
because you're indian yeah
that's awesome this is uh i agree with
you winning winning ideas so if somebody
wants to make a play on this white code
investor site i would love to you know
buy this website and do something with
it or if somebody wants to make a group
that's like this and go for it uh
dm me or email me or email sam uh and
let's let's this is a good one yeah and
he they also have conferences so they
have a uh a uh white coat investor
conference right um it's a this is a
good this is i completely agree with you
you know who could have crushed this
niche and they didn't want to was our
buddy uh
what's the youtuber ollie uh what's his
last name
yeah he could have done this yeah i
agree um yeah he chose like a worse
market he's like i'll teach people how
to become you like youtubers how to be
better at youtube like teach doctors how
to be better at money
like way better way better
if you if you if you're not passionate
about the other one all right okay
second all right so it sounds like you
like the first one here's the second
idea
the family i would say i love the first
family legacy
summit okay so basically there's a huge
number of businesses
that are owned by you know kind of like
boomer generation
that
they would love if their kids
would take on their business and like
kind of grow it kids maybe maybe
interested maybe not the kid kind of
feels like i should i guess that's a
smart move but i just don't care about
you know
where the you know making treadmills or
whatever we do you know like our family
business
um so they're kind of one foot in one
foot out but but even then they're like
okay the parent's like all right no
problem you don't have to take it over
but like
i gotta do something with this and you
should know how this works in case i
croak and like you know
you should know how the books work and
like you should know some things so
basically what you do is
through some kind of cold outreach
to uh boomerang businesses
you're gonna offer them an invite to the
family legacy summit it is a two-day
conference in florida where you're going
to have
it's got to be orlando
or jort lauderdale exactly um
like you know
for obvious reasons
the local george lauderdale or orlando
yeah we get it there's gotta be a buffet
understood exactly
the family legacies of it all you can
eat of course
yeah with new balance white sneakers as
a sponsor out loud
[Laughter]
yeah sunday loungewear no socks no
service you gotta have your socks
basically you invite people out there
and it's just education it's just a give
give give maybe there's some ticket
thing to cover the calls maybe of
sponsors i think you could cover the
whole cost of sponsors but it's just
invite only your business has to be of a
certain level of maturity so it's you
know doing over a million dollars a year
you're a family business who's thought
about this question of should we pass it
down or not you and your kids come out
so they come out and at that you're
going to do a couple things
this is now this is now the door that
opens more doors
so you could upsell them some services
so estate planning accounting uh
whatever that sort of thing
you could um
offer like upsell masterminds or like a
kind of a master's program which is like
for the kid to like take it over or
whatever something like that
you could uh just buy businesses that
like uh the kid's not gonna do it this
is lead gen for amazing businesses that
you could potentially buy out and you
sell those leads to private equity or
you buy them yourself
and um
and yeah it's a way to build a power
network in like one year you'd have like
some amazing connections because there's
going to be a guy who owns you know a
fur you know wood a wood furniture
company in tennessee that makes 22
million dollars a year and like those
people you'll be your buddies because
you're actually helping them with like
one of their core life problems that
they have which is what do i do with my
business and this like stinking kid
who's not not taking action
do you remember brent bayshore he came
on our pod um what's his what's the name
of his thing permanent equity i think
something equity permanent equity he's
based out of columbia missouri he has
this conference every year called
capital camp
which is a great name uh and
how is he doing he's basically doing
this is it well he's buying boomer
businesses how's that going i think it's
going phenomenal
i think it's going absolutely great
and our friend sieva
of which i think we're both investors
enduring ventures is doing a similar
thing um
it's maybe it's a little bit smaller but
it's just new also newer
yeah and they are buying like can we
talk about what they bought they've come
on the pod before
uh and they're pretty public about stuff
so they're buying companies like
cool uh pool construction companies so
it's like
uh you know pools are this like amazing
business that you could you could do and
they bought one in like things called
dolphin pools or something like that
they bought it in arizona it crushes it
they hired this one operator who's like
really good who took it over from the
the original owner the boomer owner and
basically
it's grown like crazy and that's like
one of their cash cows now
and i uh and they also bought a internet
web like um i got in the country like
they don't have like a t or time warner
or whatever they they have like local
providers
and they bought one of those and it's
doing well and i have family members so
my dad is an entrepreneur
they bought five different yeah a bunch
of internet service providers
and they're all doing i think pretty
good um and so my dad owns a small
business that none of his family is
taking over my father-in-law owns a
small business who
and it is a really it's a killer
business i mean um and they uh he
somehow the uh our new brother-in-law is
now gonna take it over and
seeing the turmoil that he had to go
through in order to he was like well i
spent 40 years building this thing and i
guess if no one that i love wants it i'm
just going to shut it down
and it was like kind of tragic
and it's like i'm literally willing to
give this to a family member and they
can make many millions of dollars a year
if they wanted to do this it's just it's
free you could have it and uh people
didn't want to do it
and so i've seen this process and it is
like an emotional
it's a really it's a huge challenge and
this is very a very interesting market
there's some stats about how many do you
know how many boomers are retiring and
like that's some absurd number
it's absurd it's like it's like it's
like a quarter of the country like or or
a third of the country biggest wealth
transfers of all time is about to happen
it's the like that that group of people
when they pass down their hair
it's gonna it's like many trillions of
dollars i think i don't know if that's
that might be hyperbole but i think it's
something like that some ridiculous
number
and then that's like a lot of people
that are just not gonna have to work but
also don't know what to do with it and
similarly there's many many businesses
that was when enduring first pitched it
they were like
they just showed me the stats they were
like there are this many boomer
businesses
where they want to retire they don't
want to run their business anymore and
their kids don't want to take it over
and like those businesses are up for
grabs and they're like too small like
they're not sexy as a startup and
they're too small for big private equity
and so we're going to be like basically
like permanent equity where they're
going to be
they're just going to buy it and hold
these amazing businesses for a very long
time and they keep doing that one after
another uh like i think sieve and xavier
they've rolled up like
almost 100 million dollars of business
equity off of a two million dollar
starting equity amount like we
[Laughter]
it is crazy i i invested in what i
didn't have a lot of money when i first
invested in so but at the time it was
like 10 or 15 000 i or something like
that that i invested it was like that
that was a big deal let me tell you what
happened
it's just been like it's just been
growing and growing and growing no so
they so they were like they're like sean
like you've helped us like think through
this idea and like they do like i like
the stuff i'll be helpful along the way
so they're like you know we want to
offer you like if you invest we'll also
offer you like an invest an advisor or
like like an advisory grant that'll just
match your investment and uh
and i think they thought i was gonna do
like you forgot to file the paperwork no
no no i think they thought i was gonna
put in like 25k or like max or like 20k
something like that so they're like okay
cool you get like 20k of equity we'll
give you 20k worth of advisory shares
but i was like a big believer in what
they were doing so i put in 200 000
and then they were like they're like oh
and i was like look you don't have to
like
i get it you don't have to give me 200
000 of advisor shares but xavier was
like nope a deal's a deal and um like i
was like we didn't sign anything and
like dude i'm totally okay with it but
he's like no like
like we will we'll honor that and also
like i know you'll like you'll deliver
and so since then i've had this like
immense desire to deliver on that it was
actually the best thing he ever did
because he got me to basically work for
him for free uh for this one like for
this act of goodwill i am like i will i
see your goodwill and i raise you ten
times goodwill on my own side it's gonna
that's gonna end up being a great one of
your better investments i would think
depending on i don't know when you got
in if were you with very we both were
you both yes then that's going to i
think it's going to crash exactly like i
think already let's say conservatively
that's probably up
20 x you know like something like that
in valuation you think that's up 20x
because if they go raise now they
basically have i don't know exact
numbers but like
somewhere between
25 to 50 million of
revenue
closer to 50 million in revenue from
these businesses now
um that they've acquired off of 2
million in equity
[Music]
you